i wanna sing for you
you're my favorite still
yup that's normani teasing her new
single on tick-tock i'm so excited no
i'm proud of myself the year 25-year-old
singer captioned the clip announcement
coming to you in the next coming days
which has fans thinking this is an
official taste of her upcoming album
[Music]
but i always will
the motivation singer made a similar
tease over on twitter linking out to
this website where fans can pre-save her
new music i wanna sing for you
[Music]
now we knew some new normani tunes were
on the way check out what the one time
fifth harmony member told et back in
november what do you want to tell the
fans out there who and i know you hear
it and see it who are asking where is
the album where is the album what do you
want to tell them i want to tell you
that
summer is going to be late get out yes
the summer is going to be lit so you
ready you're gearing up are you in
rehearsals are you doing it shoot we're
doing everything we're doing it all i'm
ready to perform i miss performing we
know you do you've been putting out the
hit so i'm excited to see the whole
debut
this new track will be normani's first
since dropping her cardi b collab wild
side last summer
shoot me like a watch me down on the
kitchen floor right on that towel i hope
you guys are enjoying the artwork i feel
like this is normani's big comeback and
like i want you guys to treat it like
it's her birthday and like this song
this everything is amazing and i'm just
so proud of her after putting in some
work
work
to promote that track on social media i
want to sing for you
you're my favorite still
normani pivoted to dropping hints about
her debut album
[Music]
but until she drops the official track
we'll have this latest tick tock on
repeat i want to sing for you
you're my favorite still
when i say i won't tell myself i don't
but i always
[Music]
spike
[Music]